And today we'll have a doctor.
Derek is Zachary.
What's an associate professor of psychology at northeastern university who'll be
speaking with us on emotion intention.
So he received his phd from the University of Pennsylvania working with Dr.
Martin Seligman and his Ba from Stanford University working with Dr Laura
Carstensen.
Doctors Sakowitz.
His research interests lie at the intersection of attention and emotion,
particularly among older adults.
He's received numerous honors including the American Psychological Association
Early Career Award from division 20 the Margaret m and Paul Be Bolts Foundation
Award and behavioral and Social Gerontology for outstanding early career
contributions from the Jair Gerontological Society of America,
as well as several graduate mentoring and teaching awards.
His research has been funded by grants from the NIH and doctor Zach Woods has
served on the editorial boards of several renowned journals,
including psychology and aging emotion,
as well as the Journal of personality and social psychology.
So I now turn to our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Derek [inaudible].
So welcome Derek.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Can Derek,
I wanted to start out just by asking you some questions about what first got you
interested in emotion and at the very beginning.
So I,
I sort of discovered emotion as an undergraduate at Stanford.
Um,
though I didn't come to it because of emotion per se.
I actually first got interested in the study of aging because I met Laura
Carstensen,
uh,
really one of the world experts on the psychological study of aging at a faculty
dinner during my freshman year at Stanford.
And because I thought she was really great and cool,
I decided that I wouldn't start working in her lab.
And,
um,
I learned over the course of my time in the last hub that what she was
interested in was how,
um,
social and emotional processes change with age.
So that is how I ended up studying emotion.
Um,
and I feel very fortunate to have had that,
uh,
had that encounter because it wasn't that I initially had some big question
about emotion I wanted to answer was that I was interested in aging and issues
about emotion became really interesting and important to me in the context of
aging.
Wow.
So the serendipitous discovery of emotion,
luckily they're in.
Deborah does.
So I want to ask you then a few questions about your research now that is
focused on emotion and attention.
Um,
so I mean,
you are widely known in the field for your work on attention and emotion and how
this relationship can change through the lifespan.
And I wondered from your perspective as an expert in this area,
what do you see as the most important discoveries?
Me,
the most important discoveries from my own area of research has been that
something that we consider as,
as sort of basic and fundamental as visual attention can really be flexible
depending on things like what goals people are trying to pursue.
Um,
as well as,
uh,
if that it may change over the course of development.
Um,
in that reflect shifting motivation,
shifting goals.
So I think for me it's been most exciting to see,
to try to understand differences between people of different ages and something
I think is fundamental is visual attention and to be able to investigate what
extent those changes are a function of psychological changes and what's
important to people.
And May of course have other,
I have other causes as well.
Um,
so that to me has been very exciting,
particularly in light of other research in other labs showing each differences
and processing of emotional attention,
um,
in other sorts of cognitive sorts of tasks like in memory tasks.
And what do you see as some of the biggest challenges in this line of work too?
I see two,
two sort of big challenges.
One is just the technical challenge of doing this sort of research.
I do using eye tracking to look at visual attention,
um,
in populations like older adults.
Uh,
these technologies were not designed really to,
uh,
for use in groups of people who,
who his eyes may not have a typical features,
uh,
that we would expect from a,
from younger adults who have assistants were designed for.
So there's the technical challenge of doing something like eye tracking to study
attention and older people.
And then there's this sort of pragmatic challenge of,
you know,
the reason I'm interested in eye tracking with older people is not just because
I want to understand it,
I movement,
but because I want to understand the cognitive processes that help people of
different age is a regulate how they feel in real time.
And so the other big challenges that predicting how people feel in real time,
it was really complicated.
Um,
I might be interested in attention is one predictor,
but in the course of everyday life,
um,
there are lots of things that happen that may or may not affect our mood and the
short and long term.
So it's been really challenging methodologically to be able to try to predict
realtime mood change and how that varies by age.
I think we're making progress,
but it's been quite tricky.
Well,
all that being said,
I mean you do such sophisticated,
beautiful work,
um,
in spite of all the challenges that year,
you know,
outlining right now.
Um,
I mean,
and in that vein,
you know,
you've continued to do work really looking at how age related changes in the
relationship between attention and emotion shifted across time.
And I just wonder here what you think research tells us about the sort of modify
ability of attention as another important component of emotion regulation more
generally.
It's interesting,
we initially started doing this work because of our interest specifically in age
differences,
but as we found patterns of each difference that suggested that the ways in
which individuals use their attention to regulate their emotions change changes
with age.
It raised very,
what I think are natural questions about the extent to which we can through time
or through intervention change or attention in a way that influence emotional
regulation.
If that happens naturally with age,
it makes sense to ask how that might have in other formats as well.
And so this has led I think quite naturally just thinking things like,
for example,
meditation,
um,
students in my lab who are more having more direct experience than I do.
He's telling me that,
you know,
one of the main reasons that people are interested in meditation is because they
believe that in that,
that they can use techniques of meditation to help train your attention because
they think that that will improve their wellbeing.
And so that's sort of an implicit belief about being able to train attention for
emotion regulation.
So I see a lot of parallels between what we can learn about aging and each
differences in how people use attention to regulate their emotions.
And something like meditation where people are intentionally trying to write
change their retainage and to regulate emotion.
And there are a lot of parallels in a lot of lessons,
uh,
between those two areas in terms of what's possible and also what's not going to
be possible in terms of changing attention for emotion regulation.
I mean,
in speaking of parallels,
you've also written about these parallels between aging and disorders of
emotion.
So you've written a nice review looking at the relationship between positivity
bias in both,
you know,
aging or older adults as well as individuals.
So the history of mania or bipolar disorder and in what ways can we really see
sort of parallels as well as possible differences between these two kind of
fundamentally different groups of people.
Yeah.
This,
that project really started as a thought experiment did it most of the
experiment?
Yeah,
because I think in the aging area it's become so widely accepted that older
adults show positivity in their emotional processing and in their experience
that it's,
there hasn't been much of a dialogue with other areas in which people talk about
positivity biases.
So I thought it would be useful to think about parallels and similarities and
differences with other areas of that.
Got me in discussions with people studying bi polar disorder.
And you know,
clearly what we are starting point was that here are two groups of people,
older people and people with,
uh,
with bipolar disorder were thought to have some sort of positive offset in some
aspect of their experience and or regulation and where their processing of
emotional information.
So he said,
well,
how are these offsets explained,
uh,
in the literature?
What are the conceptual models and what do we know empirically about,
uh,
about that?
It turns out that,
you know,
it's quite hard to make any definitive conclusions because in large part,
the methods that are used in one field who've not been translated into the
other.
So for example,
um,
apparently I've learned from,
uh,
from colleagues in this area that there are numerous studies and the bipolar
bipolar literature on goal frustration and we don't have any of those and they
aging literature,
but it would be a really good thing for somebody to do.
Um,
so we've been limited by the lack of sort of a formal parallels in research.
it for me with mostly interesting to think about,
um,
you know,
we have a tendency to interpret older adults.
Positivity is a great thing.
Um,
and uh,
and clearly that's not the case in,
in bipolar and even though it's sort of a,
maybe a trait conclusion,
I think it's an important conclusion that our interpretation of the positivity
offsets,
there's no doubt influenced by our expectations and we really want to understand
sort of group differences from,
uh,
from not from neutral negative or positive responding.
Then we started me to conceptual framework that allows us to consider when it's
adaptive and when it's not adaptive.
There may or may not be,
um,
interesting differences and our similarities and neuropathways.
I don't think we're at that point yet and neuro processes,
but,
um,
I think it will be interesting for us to keep up with over the years to see if
the literature is to become more parallel because they can instruct each other
about what,
uh,
what makes sense and what doesn't.
Yeah.
And I mean,
in terms of the literature is kind of instructing each other.
I wonder if you think either of these literatures separately,
our wind sort of put side by side can tell us anything about,
you know,
potential interventions to promote wellbeing more generally or individually in
each of these two populations,
older adults and individuals with a history of mania.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
one thing that I do think is suggested by the literature to this point,
and it may just be an artifact of what's been studied,
but to the most consistent findings of an aging literature,
we're not about enhanced positivity per se,
but more about reduction and negativity,
which does not in my reading seem to be the case in the bipolar literature.
So I,
so my belief is that if that pans out as a meaningful distinction in the two,
uh,
the two research areas,
they may be that the aging literature is going to have more implications for
intervention for reducing negative aspect,
whereas the bipolar literature,
we'll have more implications for interventions that could ramp down on
problematic,
positive effect.
Um,
that said,
I mean,
when people ask me about intervention from the aging literature is always
tricky.
My usual response is,
well,
what the literature suggests is the best intervention is to just wait sort of
that,
the positive effects of time to uh,
to take shape.
And it's only sort of half joking.
I mean,
I do think that that's when one possible lesson,
I mean the meditation parallel is one way that we try to flesh out what the
shorter term implications might be other than been waiting.
But that is sort of one implication I think of the aging literature.
Excellent.
I mean,
thank you so much for answering all these questions about kind of how you
serendipitously got into the field and motion and how you've been kind of stuck
ever since,
you know,
unraveling this mystery is about attention and emotion across the lifespan.
So the question I have for you now is all of that,
that aside,
where do you see the future of the field headed?
Sort of,
where's it going from here?
I mean,
my,
and this is maybe just my hope,
but my,
my expectation is that we'll start to see a better integration across various
levels of analysis that in an emotion research.
Um,
and to me levels of analysis,
it certainly includes the usual suspects of levels of analysis,
like biological,
neural,
behavioral,
social.
But it also includes sort of a wider net of things like,
you know,
that are interesting to me,
like,
like gauge differences,
cultural differences,
um,
because we have so many great researchers in different areas of emotion focusing
on one aspect,
one,
one of these levels of analysis either going deep or wide and um,
and eventually the hope is that we'll all come together and I think that people
were starting to bridge maybe two to,
uh,
port areas.
But I'm,
I'm optimistic that there's going to be work that really goes,
broke,
goes both broader and wider within particular questions.
And what we're seeing,
I think is that one barrier to that is different terminology,
different operational definitions.
So I'm hopeful that we can at least cross get,
get past those,
uh,
those,
those problems and obstacle is to have more common definitions and constructs
that will then allow us to take a broader view.
But that's what,
that's what I hope for.
That's excellent.
And so when you think about where you hope the future of the field and emotions
going and you have students coming to you who are interested in embarking in
this field,
uh,
what kind of advice do you give them?
Yup.
My main advice is that,
and this is clearly rooted in my own experience,
is that,
you know,
emotion is such a rich area.
It's such a hot area.
I think it's a great area for students and be in,
but I always suggest to students that they make sure to have a thing.
Um,
a,
a particular issue topic.
Um,
whether age group,
just a word or some lens through which to view emotion.
Because I think for somebody who's just interested in emotion in general,
it's so vast and it's can be hard to ground one's thinking,
um,
in,
in a literature and the tradition and the history.
So I always suggest to students that they start with one with one perspective,
again in my lab,
but would be age differences,
but another lab,
it could have been just a word or it could be some sort of cultural difference
or could be one particular flavor of emotion.
Um,
but just to have some lens in which to view things because then as you expand
out,
you have some sort of basic understanding that you take with you.
So for me,
you know,
as initially interested in aging,
so I learned all about that.
Um,
and it clearly was the lens with which I thought about emotion.
But then,
you know,
in my,
in sort of another serendipitous experience,
the reason that I ended up doing eye tracking was not because somebody in the
aging literature suggested it,
but because of anxiety you researchers suggested as we were talking about,
um,
about issues,
they said,
well,
you know,
an anxiety,
people were using eye tracking.
And I thought,
well,
maybe we could use that in aging.
And it turned out to work out really well.
And I think that if I hadn't had already been grounded in a question where I
felt like I had mastered a one perspective on literature,
I wouldn't have been as open and amenable to try and integrate and across
different literatures and try something to the sort of out of the box.
So I think that these sort of cross cutting approaches,
it may seem like I'm contradicting myself,
but I think that you need some rooting and a basic perspective to then be ready
and able to do work that sort of says,
I have this protective,
I'm going to try to break it up a little bit.
Um,
so that,
anyway,
that's the advice that I would,
but I would give.
That's fantastic advice.
Derek,
thank you so much for speaking with us today.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you very much.
Great to talk to you.
And this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Derek is
Accurate's from northeastern university.